quem de vocês aqui tem ou teve na
família aquela pessoa que sempre tem uma
receita pronta para indicar quando
alguém adoecia ou então quando alguém
está doente ela tem uma simpatia todo
mundo tem na família garanto
na minha família é essa
o guardian dessa sabedoria popular é
minha avó que daqui a dois meses
completa 100 anos de idade
e ela passou todo seu conhecimento para
minha mãe para minha tia e durante a
minha infância elas trafegavam desde a
prevenção diagnóstico e tratamento
passando por todas as especialidades que
se possa imaginar da hematologia clínica
médica pediatria obstetrícia neurologia
e até a minha própria especial da trofa
oncologia mas na minha infância
a gente já tem todo o tratamento e nós
conhecemos hoje
mas se alguém tinha crise de garganta
o tratamento era banha de tédio algumas
gotas de limão se aquecendo o fogo e
tomava aquilo eu tomei e funcionava a em
kurtkoy gialle pessoal tá certo o menino
com solos a de vincular o tratamento
menino recém nascido um chumaço de
algodão molhado na testa do menino
resolvia né
se você tem amor dela quero ter sol
alguém lembra o tratamento esquentava a
palma da mão né ou aliança e fazer uma
compressa local funciona eu determino
compressa morna para quem tem hordéolo o
pessoal se você tinha artrite e ter a
dor na articulação um presta com sebo de
carneiro capado se não fosse capaz não
tinha mesmo efeito mas é criança atacada
com o raquitismo
era o meu caso se lava a casca de ovo
peneirava e botavam na comida da criança
né
quando não era isso era o famoso óleo de
fígado de bacalhau e ficava na mesma
prateleira da rapadura porque era
impossível com aquilo que não fosse um
pedaço de rapadura depois né você
tivesse asma você ganhava no seu quarto
uma gaiola com um cão
o campeão é uma ave e acreditava que o
campeão ele trazia doença para ele mesmo
se a mulher tivesse grávida não o dia
colocar nada nos bolsos corri o risco da
criança nascer com manchas e nascença né
e outras coisas mais que a gente
hoje acha graça mas que na época
funcionava e disso tudo sobreviver 11
filhos
mais de 30 netos e mais de trinta
bisnetos e não pára de crescer o número
mas tem uma doença que elas não usavam
nem mencionar o nome
quanto mais se envolver e quando lá no
interior o sino da igreja tocava
anunciando um cortejo fúnebre de alguém
que a gente estava na sala que se
perguntava o fulano morreu de que o mal
estar é instantâneo e dizer ele morreu
daquela doença e se mudava rapidamente e
assunto porque é um assunto incómodo e
de onde vem isso vem da nossa cultura
o misticismo né o nosso organismo em
acreditar
o mau olhado mau agouro pode transmitir
uma doença
você pode adquirir se você mencionar o
nome da doença né
e numa noite
véspera de uma comemoração na nossa
família de um casamento em uns 10 anos
de idade
literalmente meu avô caiu alguns meus
pés
manifestando os primeiros sinais daquela
doença e aquela doença meus amigos nada
mais era de que cansa
e tem cunhou o termo cansa foi
hipócrates há 400 anos antes de cristo
e como ele cunhou esse termo né
quando estava examinando uma pessoa
provavelmente uma massa tumoral
superficial ele achou que ele passa
parecido com um caranguejo e aí ele
denominou que aquilo era ar nos e daí
veio o conceito e cansa né
então é na história se a gente for ver o
câncer é muito mais antigo de que a
humanidade está existe indícios de
câncer e em força isso e dinossauros que
datam mais de 70 milhões de anos
tá certo minhas da planície do atacama
da tribo filha baya estudiosos que
estavam pesquisando essa região
encontraram a minha e tem muito
ele tem uma técnica semelhante aos
egípcios
eles encontraram a mulher em torno de 30
anos de idade unificada segurando
antebraço e nesse antebraço numa massa
tumoral essa massa foi propiciada e o
diagnóstico foi mostra o sarcoma no
entanto o primeiro registro da
humanidade e tem se notícia data se a
mais de 2.600 anos antes de cristo
um médico e arquiteto chamado em ro tec
era um grão visita do egito e no papiro
e ele escreveu 48 casos clínicos médicos
dentre fraturas abscessos o caso 45 e
foi traduzido em 1930 está lá escrito
massas tumorais na mama incurável
todos os outros têm um tratamento - o
caso 45
e aí a gente também se enfrentam na
história heródoto nos descreve a
primeira cirurgia oncológica da
humanidade
a rainha após a rainha da pérsia
acometida de um câncer de mama são
grande
depois de esgotar todos os tratamentos
junto aos médicos da nobreza se valeu de
um escravo era médico chamado de monstro
sedes para fazer a amputação de sua mão
e foi feito só que de moçâmedes
convenceu a rainha a convencer o marido
dela que era dario a invadir a grécia
porque a grécia tem invadido a cidade de
mons é dia de hoje a itália então o
câncer de mama pois é responsável pela
origem de uma guerra e dario lançou mais
de mil embarcações no a ofensiva contra
a grécia
e aí meus amigos se a gente for é
seguindo na história e nas estatísticas
atuais é no mundo hoje a pose milhões de
pessoas são diagnosticadas com câncer a
cada ano ea cada ano 7 milhões padecem
da doença no brasil o câncer é a segunda
causa de morte só perdendo para as
doenças cardiovasculares ea perspectiva
é que em 2020 e frança já seja a
primeira causa de morte no brasil
e aí meus amigos essa palestra não teria
muito sentido se não fosse a minha vez
em 2014 após sentiu as dores abdominais
em específicas e procurar um colega
médico de turma
eu fui diagnosticado com aquela doença
né
em 2014 é após fazer uma tomografia
nós achamos um tumor maligno final né
células claras e nessa hora ao contrário
do que muita gente pensa saber o final
do filme nunca é legal
nunca é legal saber o cortejo que você
tem que percorrer até chegar ao final do
filme
pior ainda
nessa hora eu lembrei eu cumpro pra
vocês que eu não lembrei muito de mim eu
lembrei dos meus pacientes e em um
câncer renal e que eram todos os
pacientes terminais
e aí a coisa gravou o que eu digo todos
eram terminais roupa que você terminal
também né
e algumas frases eu me lembrei deles
botou eu estou com aquela doença ou
então do total flertando com amor e me
disse eu lembro muito bem que desbotou
em breve eu partirei
então você começa a se identificar com
essas frases né
mas cadu é de amigos de turma amigos
irmãos eu chamo eles demandam amigos né
eu fui diagnosticado eu fiquei
anestesiado e eu fui operado por colegas
meus de sala de aula tá academia de
medicina
eu sempre busco era uma bagunça nem dá
pra vocês receber mas eu me recuperei é
a recuperação foi é fantástica né
e depois que eu me recuperei eu sentei
eu em uma conversa informal com minha
mãe
eu descobri que três outras pessoas na
minha família também tiveram retirar um
rico aos as obscuras o teu pai ninguém
contou isso que eu tenho três pessoas na
minha família que tiraram ruim eu não
sabia um médico
por causa da nossa crença e se falar em
dança a coisa piora e o câncer renal ele
tem causas hereditárias e genéticas
determinada
então se eu tenho câncer os meus
descendentes têm mais riscos
então eu preciso criá los e eu só foi
possível me tratar porque o meu
diagnóstico foi precoce a então três
outras pessoas removeram o o oe né
foi aí que eu parei disse bem eu te vi
toda chance de dar o diagnóstico precoce
e as pessoas que não têm o que eu posso
fazer
nessa época a gente já estava
desenvolvendo alguns dispositivos que
acoplado ao celular estava diagnóstico
de baixo ou na oftalmologia é tornando
mais acessível à saúde
pra quem não tem condições e aí nós
desenvolvemos um teste de urina para o
celular não é pra urinando celular
pessoal todo mundo pergunta uepa
originando celular mas é um dispositivo
de baixo custo em que você tem um chip
que você mora na amostra do paciente
o néctar nesse suporte bater uma foto e
um software que a gente desenvolveu da
todas as dosagens 10 segundos uma
precisão muito maior do que o teste de
urina convencional que vocês conhecem
então vocês imaginem e se eu tiver o que
a gente chama hoje de maturéia
microscópio e pode ser por outras causas
ou infecção o cálculo renal
mas isso pode ser um indício de câncer
de bexiga
então a gente tentou deixar esse legado
pra uma coisa e baixíssimo isto né
acessível a todo mundo todos vocês em
celular e que possa servir de uma
triagem imaginem vocês se eu tiver um
agente de saúde um aparelho desse
andando no bairro fazendo exame mandando
para uma central de agnósticos em antes
mesmo do paciente ao médico médico já
tem o exame dele
então isso muda a logística da saúde
pública como a gente conhece hoje e é
nisso que a gente trabalha
e na oftalmologia já que os
oftalmologistas o que eu poderia fazer
né então conversando com um amigo nosso
a gente soube que mais de 200 pessoas
estão mutiladas no nosso estado o câncer
ocular periocular ou então por traumas e
aí nós tivemos outra idéia que foi criar
um projeto para doar essas próteses já
que o sistema público não estava doando
as próprias e essas pessoas estavam
enclausurados em suas casas porque
estava com sua dignidade completamente
rebaixada
como é que a pessoa vai encontrar
emprego estudar sem ter um olho e aí nós
tivemos a ideia junto com outros
parceiros e colaboradores de criar nossa
própria agência de pesquisa inovação e
desenvolvimento sem fins lucrativos né
para tentar fazer valer o
desenvolvimento sócio econômico de nossa
região tentando garimpar projetos em
prol dessa ideologia que nós pensamos e
conseguimos já do algumas próteses em
parcerias com indústrias de são paulo e
outros parceiros locais e você não tem
noção do que é você dar dignidade a uma
pessoa que estava desempregado e voltou
a trabalhar porque restaurou sua a sua
aparência e um menino que não estudava e
passou a estudar então é na olímpiada
agora de 2016 esse polonês foi medalha
de prata e ele tornou a medalha de prata
de ouro leiloando a a medalha para
arrecadar dinheiro para tratar o pequeno
moleque etapa com retinoblastoma que é
um tumor maligno do olho que a coleta
criança desde que ela nasce pode
acometer ainda dentro da barriga da mãe
e vai o pico até os três anos de idade e
o tratamento geralmente é remoção do
globo ocular eu já tive pacientes que eu
tive que dar a notícia aos pais com
tumores nos dois olhos
e aí o que fazer então com um grupo de
são paulo nós estamos desenvolvendo um
dispositivo que pode ser operado por um
leigo e que você vai bater a foto da
criança e os
o software vai dar o diagnóstico dizendo
se está alterado ou se está normal não
tem como eu fazer um aparelho de alto
custo para os pacientes virem a mim isso
não existe mais
quem pensava medicina dessa forma está
na contramão é do do futuro e como é o
futuro o futuro é promissor pessoal não
é só uma notícia não o futuro é muito
promissor agora baseado em dois
alicerces na ciência e na informação na
ciência desenvolvendo novas drogas novas
tecnologias para o diagnóstico precoce e
na informação pra você fazer o
diagnóstico precoce você tem fator de
risco então 70% hoje descansa já são
curados eu sou a prova viva estou aqui
no palco falando para vocês e se acha
que os que não são curados não se
tornado doenças crônicas compatível com
a qualidade de vida adequada
nós temos que falar de câncer aquela
doença é o cansa eu tive cansa e eu me
tratei do cansa e eu fui curado do
câncer
então a gente não pode deixar de falar
em cansa porque a nossa o nosso silêncio
só alimenta as estatísticas e fortalece
essa doença nefasta
obrigado a todos
[Aplausos]